my name is Jeff staple I'm here today to
answer your questions from Twitter this
is sneaker support
[Music]
[Applause]
to be proven conclusively who had the
superior shoe technology Nike Air or
Reebok Pump they do different things
Nike Air visible air Reebok Pump right
over here Nike Air this visible air unit
that you see that on this particular
shoe is completely crazy in next level
is a cushioning performance element it
supports your heel strike so that every
time you pound your foot on the pavement
it's more and more comfortable pump
pump does something a little bit
different pump inflates a bladder on the
top of your shoe and locks your foot
down so it's kind of like a replacement
to shoe laces so it's kind of hard to
really compare but if you're looking at
dollars as a metric then I would say
Nike Air fully did the Mortal Kombat
death blow to Reebok Pump Jess engs asks
why are Air Jordans so popular Air
Jordan in case you don't know is a
separate brand that is actually owned by
Nike simota Converse Converse is also a
separate brand owned by Nike if Air
Jordan were separated out of Nike and
made its own company it would still be a
top five brand in the entire world why
are they so popular Michael Jordan is
the goat there's plenty of great
basketball players that are around Kevin
Durant LeBron James Kobe Bryant rest in
peace we all know the greats if you look
at Sneaker sales of all of these
athletes it really proves who the actual
goat is Alicia forgione has is asked
real question are sneakers cool because
of the name brand or because of the
actual design of the shoe I would like
to think it's designed still but I know
the hype is real recently Payless Shoe
Source did an experiment where they took
a store in a mall and created a high-end
luxury brand image and then just put
Payless shoe product in that store and
people were chomping it up they were
just eating it like crazy they loved it
and it was really an interesting social
experiment because it showed the smoke
and mirrors of branding can overcome the
actual Footwear design Jay took stock
says designers what's a good way to
improve my logo design I feel like the
courses I find don't align to the styles
of sneaker Twitter there's a couple of
different ways to approach logo designs
some of the early logo designs such as
Adidas and the three stripes and the New
Balance n the logo originally was
stitched Fabric or leather onto the side
of your shoe so when those three stripes
come across the medial and lateral side
of your foot they're actually offering
extra support and then you've got logos
that are just purely ornamental a great
example of that is the Nike Air Jordan
Jumpman logo that is actually not an
easy logo to work with like a little
human being that you have to place
around it's obviously one of the most
important logos of all time so that
being said your logo that you're
designing for your shoe can pretty much
be anything it could start with form
function what does it do for me and my
and my fit or it could be strictly
ornamental it could be your signature
make sure it's something that you can
really believe in and live with long
term and it'll be a good logo for you
souls and laces asks is Nostalgia
hindering design innovation in the
sneaker industry this is a hot take I'm
warning you now I think the answer is
yes what souls and laces is talking
about is for example the Air Jordan 1 is
still one of the most popular shoes out
of all time in the year 2023 even though
this shoe is damn near three decades
plus old when you're making bajillions
of dollars off of this old shoe why do
you need to spend resource energy and
time into making new shoes we could just
put different colors on this old shoe
and we're good to go we'll make a couple
more billion dollars right I think if
someone were to be like a rude parent
and was like no more Air Jordan one you
now have to think of the new thing we're
not going to survive unless you think of
the greatest Air Jordan 40 ever then I
think the Air Jordan 40 is gonna be
better than if you had the Air Jordan 1
making billions of dollars for you
Jasmine keona asks ever wonder what goes
into the shoemaking process hmm Emoji
most sneaker designers want to start at
the bottom to the top to the outside so
what I mean by that is usually start at
the outsole the reason why is because
the outsole is the most complicated part
to make so once you have this done then
you could start working on the upper and
the upper can change it could be
different materials it could be
different shapes so for instance if you
don't like this piece here anymore in
the first design and you want to change
that piece as long as you've got your
bottom done it's much easier to do that
so you're working your way up to the top
once you've got your uppers done this is
called the upper then you've got your
accoutrements such as your laces things
like tongue label logo the logo hit on
the side prints on the back these are
all different elements that help
identify and make a shoe unique and
special Christy mofot asks for those of
us who know absolutely nothing about
sneaker culture but want to learn
where's a good place to start there are
a couple of really good documentaries
out now that are really really well made
one is made by David friendly called
sneaker heads and then the other movie
that's out is called Just for kicks you
watch them you're going to get a really
good understanding of sneaker culture
and you'll see a lot more of me in them
too Alright bugs mini asks how did
sneaker culture go from OG 80s Air
Jordans one of the dopest designs in
human history to these things that look
like condoms or aliens that's not a shoe
that's a fossilized slug this is what is
important for sneaker designers to
understand when this shoe came out in
the 80s and 90s this shoe was literally
banned from the NBA Michael Jordan was
fined five thousand dollars a game for
wearing this shoe and the stakeholders
at the NBA said this is too crazy too
ugly and violates all the rules of the
NBA we are finding you every time you
wear this shoe so as a designer you have
to put yourself and zoom out and say
something that actually polarizes me
today may be a staple tomorrow right so
40 years from now these alien condoms
may be a classic Staple in the future
for your children or grandchildren Nell
buzzin asks when it comes to fashion and
sneakers what does hypebeast mean
somebody who depends on who you're
asking maybe cares a little bit too much
about fashion and Footwear that's what a
hypebeast is if you find yourself buying
doubles of things so that you can keep
one to rock and keep one to stock or AKA
Keep On Ice you might be a hype Beast if
you find yourself wearing a pair of
shoes on a rainy day and then when you
come home you sacrifice your own
toothbrush to clean a pair of shoes you
might be a hypebeast there too hypebeast
kind of has a negative derogatory term
in this day and age I still love it I
still think hypebeast just means people
who really care about the origin story
and why things are made they care about
all the details they cherish them and
they savor it alright by Brandon white
has asked how do Big Brand sneaker
collaborations work what's the process
like as a designer are they pitching you
an idea or vice versa it kind of goes
all different ways if you're a lesser
known designer and you have an idea
you're probably going to be knocking on
doors trying to get your ideas brought
to light I would advise maybe getting
into the Footwear industry in any aspect
another way that's been really popular
as of late is individuals and if you've
got the the chops and the skills to do
this they start making a name for
themselves online on social media they
create these really cool things it
doesn't even have to be real things they
could just be renderings that your
posting and they start tagging the
brands that they really like there are
people that work at Footwear Brands
whose sole job it is to look on social
media for the next Talent so if you tag
these people enough and they're like yo
this guy's actually really got skills
you will get that phone call or
hopefully they slide into your DMs all
right loves Ace asks I just want to know
how people be wearing Chuck Taylors like
they're comfortable I must agree with
you there I have a shoe here by feyway
the bottom of this Bayway is very
similar to the bottom of a Chuck Taylor
I don't find them comfortable I think
it's definitely a fashion over form type
thing people like the look of a Chuck
Taylor and in fact if you go to your
local gym you probably see a lot of
people doing deadlifts and squats in
Chuck Taylor's it's because the Chuck
Taylor is so flat to the ground there's
no arch support whatsoever but when
you're lifting heavy weights you
actually don't want arch support you
actually basically want to be barefoot
but the next closest thing to that is
the Chuck Taylor jbk Mac asks what makes
an iconic sneaker the colorway or the
cut actually Jay it's neither you know
what makes it iconic sneaker you you at
home buying shoes wearing shoes talking
about shoes online you are the people
that makes a shoe an icon a designer
cannot do that an influencer cannot do
that and an athlete cannot do that and I
can prove that by counting the number of
athletes designers and influencers that
put out shoes that don't mean crap in
the world it's only the public that can
determine what makes a shoe an icon
Marky Mark asks did the resale sneaker
market crash yet this is a very topical
question because yes the sneaker market
right now is starting to decline in
Crash currently I think the sneaker
brands have sort of wised up and said
hey we're making too little amount of
shoes there's too much resale it's too
hard for people to just walk into a
store and buy shoes so they're ramping
up production to meet the demand they're
over producing right now and what's
happening is shoes are sitting meaning
you can actually go on Foot Locker go on
to any app and just sort of buy the
shoes that you want really easily in the
size that you want at the price that was
original only charged for and what that
means is that the resale Market is
beginning to crash and decline land's
dead asks Nike is developing the power
laces from Back to the Future how gotta
see this that is right this is what's
known as the Air Mag Marty McFly
strapped these on Back to the Future too
Auto lacing was born but then Nike
decided to start realizing how this
could maybe become a reality it's called
Nike Hyper adapt that is the new name
for auto lacing it is actually connected
to your smartphone it is also connected
to either Alexa or Siri you could
literally walk home and say Hey Siri
unlace my shoes they will unlace and you
could just kick them off you can say Hey
Siri I'm about to go into game it'll
tighten it up for you it's pretty
amazing so shout out to Nike for
actually making power laces a real thing
garrickson Studio my homies out in
Philly asked what materials do you want
to see more of in sneaker design I
really am loving what's happening with
knit shoes so as you can see traditional
sneakers are using lead other nubucks
and suede more modern shoes like this
one is a completely knit upper and you
can actually knit a high top a mid top
you can knit these patterns in it you
can make it all different sort of funky
colors you can even knit in eye lace
stays and holes so that your laces can
Loop into it there's much much less
waste it's much better for the
environment it's also much more
customizable you could also do different
knit densities so you could have areas
that are like tighter on your foot and
looser on your foot to sort of mimic
what's going on on a traditional sneaker
so I really am hopeful for the
Innovation and future of knit Footwear
design JD Sports ass wow JD Sports what
up JD Sports you're a big store if you
could only wear one pair of sneakers
what are you picking people might even
say this is not a pair of sneakers but I
think it is now I would wear Crocs if I
had to pick one pair of shoe for the
rest of my life because these are damn
comfortable I think during covid Crocs
really gained the benefit because people
just started wearing these a at home all
the time then to walk their dog then
before you know it they're going to the
zoo bar getting Crocs then they're going
to the mall in Crocs and before you know
they're going on first dates and
weddings and Crocs it just became like a
thing and there's no turning back all
right that's all the questions hope you
had fun hope you learned something until
next time
foreign